hello guys and welcome to another video  today there's some very exciting news  about episode 9 and that is now that we  have the official release date and that  is May 24 2009 teen this is actually  very surprising to me as rogue one when  the forks a week and have released in  December and now episode nine is making  a change in released in May much always  I'm making this change but maybe because  I think it could grow small money in May  but I guess we have to wait and see  would you remember Stoller's the last  Jedi was also going to release the me  but then it got pushed back to December  so that is about everything about this  video so make sure to tell me your  thoughts in the comment section below  and don't forget to Like subscribe and  may the force be with you